the next Ghost Recon game is taking us
to the wild lands of Bolivia and thanks
to a new trailer we know a little bit
more about the war will be waging
against the drug cartel I'm Tony and
this is a wild game spot news update the
new Ghost Recon wildlands trailer
highlights some of the locations will be
visiting like mountain ranges railways
villages and construction sites and to
get around these places the squad will
ride along and jeeps boats tanks and
helicopters if that's up your alley then
you might want to check out some of wild
lands special editions the seventy
dollar deluxe edition includes several
digital bonuses like emblems weapon
skins and customization items the
hundred dollar gold edition includes all
the digital items plus all the upcoming
season pass content and some exclusive
weapons and vehicles then there are
three tiers of the collector's edition
priced at 120 130 and 160 bucks these
include your choice of the standard
deluxe or gold edition plus a Santa
Muerte figurine and collectible poster
Ghost Recon wildlands is headed to ps4
xbox one and pc no specific release date
has been set so you have some time to
figure out which Edition you want to
grab and you can always pre-order the
game for a bonus mission for all the
latest on Ghost Recon you're already in
the right place